do not wish health and wealth
but wish good luck
because on the titanic everyone was rich
and healthy
and only a few were lucky
success is not final
failure is not fatal
it is the courage to continue that
counts
if we open a quarrel between past and
present
we shall find that we have lost the
future
people are great at keeping secrets they
don't know
success is stumbling from failure to
failure
with no loss of enthusiasm
tact is the ability to tell someone to
go to hell
in such a way
that they look forward to the trip
kites rise highest against the wind
not with it
the greatest lesson in life is to know
that even fools are right sometimes
continuous effort not strength or
intelligence
is the key to unlocking our potential
one ought never to turn one's back on a
threatened danger and try to run away
from it
if you do that
you will double the danger
but if you meet it promptly and without
flinching
you will reduce the danger by half
if you're going through hell
keep going
[Music]
do you want your last word in an
argument
tell your opponent perhaps you are right
we live in an era of big events and
small people
a pessimist sees the difficulty in every
opportunity
an optimist sees the opportunity in
every difficulty
courage is what it takes to stand up and
speak
courage is also what it takes to sit
down and listen
to improve
is to change
to be perfect is to change often
this is no time for ease and comfort
it is time to dare and endure
you can never tell whether bad luck may
not after all
turn out to be good luck
[Music]
i am fond of pigs
dogs look up to us
cats look down on us
pigs treat us as equals
courage is rightly esteemed at the first
of human qualities
because it is the quality which
guarantees all others
we are masters of the unsaid words
but slaves of those we let slip out
i never worry about action
but only inaction
the power of man has grown in every
sphere except over himself
the inherent vice of capitalism is the
unequal sharing of blessings
the inherent virtue of socialism is the
equal sharing of miseries
you have enemies
good
that means you've stood up for something
sometime in your life
power is a drug
whoever has tried it at least once is
poisoned by it forever
we make a living by what we get
but we make a life by what we give
every man should ask himself each day
whether he is not too readily accepting
negative solutions
you